let's uh i don't know where
what's happening now where it's going
you asked
when we started you asked about the
events that are happening now
uh and of course the answer is you can
the they can either
go to it into egoic channels
and then they create more havoc
but eventually that's fine too because
eventually that too will awaken you
just means more suffering has to come
first
or it may be possible of people who want
to bring about change
that they are more conscious and
i always i love it when i see people
demonstrating peacefully
is a wonderful thing just a peaceful
demonstration is where people are
you know and the peaceful demonstration
does not demonize
other human beings that's the important
thing
if you start demonizing or groups of
humans
uh for example because that is ego
that the and it's satisfying it's so
satisfying to the ego i can say look at
these
green oh it inflates the ego
which you can demon police there's a lot
that needs to be changed but
in the way policing
and there are of course policemen who
are or women
whose ego gets enormous satisfaction
from
the power they have
and the ego loves that you're very
unconscious
but that it is absurd to say that uh
all police are evil it's just totally
absurd there are many
good human beings who do a very
difficult job and yet
yes we need to change the whole
structure and the way that it is done
that's necessary but then if we go
further and and then
we go into another trap with
the egoic trap and we could totally
astray
um but that's fine too if that has to
happen
then you will regress and regression
in consciousness is is also a way of
evolving and that's an interesting fact
that the universe evolves not
through order the play between
order and disorder order and chaos
cosmos and chaos cosmos means order
chaos means disorder so
we need the to operate continuously
both in a person's life and in the life
of the collective
we always think when of course we should
strive for order in our lives
it's good to just to strive for
be building things up creating things
that all part of
order creating things building things up
and so on but no matter whether you
should strive for order
no matter how bad you strive you will
encounter
the eruption of disorder into your life
in one way or another
it will it cannot because that's how the
universe evolves
because everything
when i walk in the forest here
the forest is a coming together of chaos
and order because when you look at the
soil
it's full of decaying plants there's
deaths everywhere every
all the vegetation the soil and the
scent that emanates from the soil it's
decaying matter this something
dissolving
but the decaying matter is food for the
new life that's arising the two go
together
and on a human level the evolution of
consciousness
often needs a regression into disorder
because
because before a new level of
consciousness can be reached
in my own life also i had to go into
despair
and near i do want to find a point of
near suicide before an awakening
happened
it was necessary my life was just
falling apart in my mind
it was i couldn't take it anymore
complete chaos
and it was i so it's often the case that
the regression is necessary for next
level of
evolution to happen and
that's whether this is happening now
we'll wait and have to see it but it
sometimes it is possible for evolution
also to happen
without the regression from time to time
but in this
where we are now it doesn't matter where
it is i see the whole
in long term term i'm very very
optimistic
about the evolution of human
consciousness not necessarily
short term but i'm a short-term
undecided but i'm a long-term
optimist because i know that the
evolution of consciousness
is inevitable because that's the entire
purpose of the universe
is the evolution of consciousness the
universe is an awakening being
it is one being manifesting through
countless forms of life but every form
of life
whether it's a person or an animal or
tree every form of life
is a temporary expression that the one
underlying being has taken
so there's this and and gradually this
this one underlying being uh
is in the process of creating
this universe it would be wrong to
believe that the creation of the world
is already finished
or that the creation of humans is a fit
if humans are
finished product it would be very sad
you just can't do god can god do better
than that
if that's different but not humans you
want is
they're awakening an awakening species
and that's fine so
i'm quite happy with the way things are
going
if we need a regression
there's a french expression excuse my
french but it's
regulated which means something like
to step back in order to jump
better when you want to jump you have to
go back first and then
you jump so there often the regressive
step is necessary but it's not
perhaps always necessary so
we'll have to see